so he first showed me this article when
we were in London we were walking around
we were doing some shopping he was like
yo I need you to look at this article
somebody wrote about me and I could not
believe what I was reading it starts off
with this which is Josh Wolf is an
American comedian actor and writer known
for his hilarious standup performances
and appearances on television shows such
as Chelsea Lately My Name is Earl and
Raising Hope these are all true all of
those are true yeah while his comedic
Talent is undeniable many Manny fans
often wonder about his physical stature
in this article we will delve into the
topic of how tall is Josh Wolf by the
way can I tell you last night those new
boots that I had they add like two or
three inches I I may just wear them all
the time you were still shorter than me
I was still shorter than you but six
foot is such a happy place to live
absolutely it is God is that is that now
I know why tall people look down on us
short [__] cuz they're like they're
living in a different world whole
different whole different temperature 6
feet and I was like oh yeah man I was
feeling myself at six feet absolutely
yeah absolutely five interesting facts
about Josh Wolf interesting fact number
one Josh Wolf stands at an impressive
height of 6 feet three inches that's
right that is so wrong I couldn't even
the number six already off the bat is
wrong you're 5'10 5'11 510 don't stop it
you 510 I'm like 510 and 3/4 you're like
510 and a half if anything I'll give you
the half inch but you're 510 I'm did
Dan's 510 not a single chance in hell
Dan's 510 if Dan's 510 I'm 74 I am Dan
Wolf is not 510 Dan Wolf is barely
pushing 5'9 maybe I can't wait to clip
this I can't yeah uh but I'm 510 and
three4 510 we're going to stick at that
this makes him significantly taller than
the average American male which measures
around 5 foot n he's not significantly
taller than that cuz he's only 510 well
listen dude even if you're saying I'm
just 5'10 I am significantly taller than
5'9 an inch is not significantly taller
it is when you're dealing between 5'9
and 510 that's like between 5'11 and 6
foot it's a significant inch yes but
also not it's significant like that was
my nickname in high school significant
inch
for by the way a great name for a rapper
significant inch is a great name for a
rapper yeah dude topnotch his height
grants him a commanding presence on
stage and Screen enhancing his comedic
performances I I I doubt that this next
one number two towering over Chelsea
Handler pause again she's like the same
[__] height as she is not the same
height as me you stop that right now
she's a she is not the same height as me
she's 56 no she's not 56 Chelsea's not
56 56 we'll see about that Josh Wolf
gained a widespread recognition as a
frequent guest on the popular night talk
show True standing at 6' three true wolf
often towered over Chelsea Handler at 56
this height became a reoccurring joke
this height difference became a
reoccurring joke and add an extra layer
of humor to their onscreen banter we
never joked about my not once was there
a joke about height in there anywhere
like she joked about my dick a couple
times until I was like hey you know my
kids yeah watch this show she was like
I'll stop I said thanks appreciate
it that yeah there was never a joke ever
made about that no no no because I was
6'3 what's there to joke about a
competitive Advantage interesting fact
three Jos Wolf's tall sat has
occasionally served as an advantage in
his personal life as a professional a
former professional football player yeah
yeah I don't know where they did their
research but whoever did the research is
should be
fired imediately I listen dude as a
former let's be honest I could have
played professional football at at 63
with my athletic ability what athletic
ability the 63 athletic ability I've
seen dudes who are 7 ft with zero
athletic ability yeah but that's not me
I'm 63 with pre primee Premier athlete
ability disagree as a former
professional football player being
standing at 6'3 gave him an edge on the
field his height allowed him to see over
the offensive line and locate open
receivers enhancing his quarterback
skills during his plays I by the way I
really you can't even throw a football
anymore I really well I could when I was
playing
I I really want to talk to the person
who wrote this article just to see where
they got got their information from yo
dude cut back to that number four
interesting fact about Josh Wolf I
wouldn't piss off piss off the 6 fo
three Josh Wolf he's real manad yeah
he's not even real
so I'm can piss him off all I
want because he does not exist he does
ask this person in this alternate
universe with on the Internet it's real
the perfect wingman interesting fact
number four being tall also has its
advantage in Social settings Joshua's
height has lent itself well to being the
perfect wingman for his friends whether
it's helping them stand out in a crowded
room or providing an extra sense of
security which by the way like I was The
Bodyguard or you were their father like
that's let me tell you something by the
way I'm not a good wingman when you're
out picking up women for this
reason I am going to make fun of you
yeah you're not going to make them look
good no the whole point is so they don't
get like I'm going to be like I'm going
to be like I really appreciate you
talking to most people the herpes is a
is a big no but you seem to be okay with
it yeah it's that I know for a fact that
is the last thing you would do actually
is try and make your friends look good
and also how are you helping them stand
out in a crowded room if you're 63
because people see me I'm real tall and
they come over and talk to me yeah but
they're coming to talk to you not to the
shorter dude they come they come talk to
me as a football star obviously that can
see over the offensive line they come
come talk to me and then I introduce him
with my [__] vagina neck look at that
thing why I just like how they kept
repeating towering presence in this
article like like you're the [__]
Statue of Liberty or something like I I
don't I
don't I'm so confused okay don't be dude
this don't be confused by my Giant
stature oh I'm not confused because
again it doesn't
exist embracing his height fun fact
number five unlike some celebrities who
may feel self ious about their height
which by the way if you're tall and a
celebrity I don't think your height is
what you're self-conscious
about I I doubt it yeah probably sorry
about that Joshua fully Embraces his
towering statue he often say that again
say again Joshua fully Embraces his
towering statue that's right in his
dreams he often incorporates his height
into his comedy routines no he doesn't
making jokes about his long Limbs and
challenges of being a tall
person you have never once experienced
any of the challenges of a tall person I
I have at almost 6 feet tall all I two
inches away from it no dude two in away
from an inch away two inches away from
it an inch
two an inch
two inch two two not only that but I I
like it the experience of being so but I
do hear you know what I hear a lot the
opposite when people meet me they're
like I thought you'd be taller it's
funny when people meet me they're like
why are you so tall and I'm like
guys I've I've explained I've said my
height as many times as I think I could
it's so funny people like I thought
you'd be taller I'm like why they like
you you look taller on TV I do how can
you judge that yeah how because how big
is your TV you know who's a shockingly
tall person who I didn't expect them to
be Gordon Ramsey yeah you told me that I
wouldn't expected him D he's like my
height I would have thought he was my
height I yeah I agree like I'm I'm not
trying to insult Jeff Ramsey here but he
gives off not 6'3 on TV then again I
can't tell how tall people are based on
looking at you on TV but he just doesn't
give off and dude he's jacked jacked
he's in great shape like it's ridiculous
he's bigger than you but he's shaped
like I am better shaped than you stop it
dude his arms are bigger than yours well
my arms are pretty small right now he's
a big guy he's a big guy like so that
was shocking but how how's his how are
his abs I had didn't ask him to lift up
his shirt when I exactly exactly uh
exactly what exactly what point are you
proving here exactly great
talk by doing
so he EST Josh Wolf establishes a
relatable connection with his audience
and showcases his ability to find humor
in everyday situations which is true but
not about his hype that I don't yeah I I
love the fact that it says that I use my
long dangly arms it also makes me laugh
because I'm going now and there's common
questions about Josh Wolf's height all
of these questions I'm going to tell you
right now these questions were written
by the dude who answer who who wrote the
article cuz all of them are just repe
repeting the exact things he already
answered on this what's the questions
the first one is like how tall is Josh
Wolf y Josh Wolf stands at an impressive
height of 6'3 yes he does cap number two
is Josh Wolf taller than Chelsea hler
yes yes Josh Wolf is taller than Chelsea
hler he 63 he's 510 Chelsea hler is 56
51 and 510 and three quarters which we
already went over was Josh Wolf you know
what we're GNA do we're g to get a
[__] measuring height in here next
time we record okay and I am going to
stand right up against it okay you're
not six are you 63 63 in shoes I'm 6'2
without
them okay but I'm usually in shoes when
people meet me so I just tell them I'm
6'2 63 I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna measure myself I here's what I'm
guessing for
real 510 and a half is what I'm guessing
for real that's what I would guess for
real yeah wait are we pushing my hair
down or we let hair down absolute hair
down if you would hair up you'd be six
seven yeah yeah yeah and 510 and a half
all the yeah yeah it's just yeah this
this article is has Josh wol ever played
basketball due to his height while there
is no public record of him playing
basketball professionally his height
would certainly give him advantage and
advantage on the court what's the name
of the person who wrote this article gbt
can we put that chat gbt can we can we
it doesn't even say who wrote it they're
too embarrassed to name can I can I see
yeah uh hold let me see if there's any
other funny questions in this uh oh oh
how did Josh Wolf transition from
football to Comedy after an injury cut
his football career short he discovered
his talent for comedy and began pursuing
a career Where did Joshua play
professional football oh good question
do you want me to answer it can I tell
you the best part they didn't give you a
team was it in the AFL yeah it says
joshu will played professional football
in the arena football league but it
doesn't site which team you played for
well listen I played for all of them you
played for none of them I played for all
of them I was so good that they had me
play quarterback for every team you you
played for them in your dreams I for
sure did not play in the AFL in my
dreams if I'm Dreaming dreaming AFL that
is not what happen it's like dreaming
about playing triaa baseball yeah dude
I'm not I'm not dreaming of the AFL that
oh go to the top it might tell you at
the top who wrote it I went to the I
went to the bottom and it didn't say but
that article kills me I mean what the
hell yeah it doesn't say who wrote it I
think chat gbt is accurate by the way H
really yeah because nobody in their
right saying mind would write all of
those when they have no facts to back it
up uh I mean has Josh ever addressed his
height in interviews yeah he addresses
his height in various interviews I don't
think you ever have no of course not not
even one time no no no that's because
nobody would ever ask me about my height
because I'm clearly six feet because
you're clearly the average height oh my
God so there's a lot of this person
wrote a lot
of articles that I'm going to
read like
uh oh yeah this is going to be good this
is I'm GNA get high tonight and check
that out hilarious